la causa es delicada
nada más
[Música]
como la que está bueno se perdieron la
introducción acá en la imagen porque
estuvo bastante espectacular es como un
gran placer que nos reunimos aquí como
todos los viernes con ustedes para
presentarles nuestro programa canadá en
las américas café también conocido por
su alias el castor cibernético y de este
viernes 29 de noviembre en vivo y en
directo a través de
de youtube facebook live nuestro sitio
internet y nuestra aplicación si bien
gracias a que estamos hoy y no ayer
porque ayer facebook no andaba
exacto por lo menos hoy nos acompaña
bueno hoy en estudio como ya se han
podido dar cuenta me acompañan palomas
martínez leonardo gimeno
bienvenido a bienvenido hablado me pagas
y al otro lado de la mesa ya ven a
nuestra invitada de hoy se trata de la
cantautora mexicana bien
mansell ruiz bienvenida a mansell hola
muchachas muchachas un placer tenerte
aquí con nosotros gracias por haber
aceptado la invitación es un gran gusto
y bien y un caluroso saludo a todos
ustedes allá del otro lado del micrófono
y de las de las cámaras s esperamos que
este programa sea de su agrado tratamos
de hacerlo lo más agradable mente
posible con mansell ruiz con nuestra
invitada vamos a hablar hoy entre otras
cosas de su último disco que acaba de
salir soleil del link
a un hombre bien particular en francés
que lo traducimos en español como sol de
luna
exactamente bueno entonces pues vamos a
conversar con marcel de eso y de mucho
más pero antes de internar nos antes de
darle rienda suelta al castor
cibernético resueltamente imagino un
montón de cosas imagínate
galope acelerarse
no sé si tienen ustedes algo inédito
para comenzar un hábito para comenzar
estamos terminando el futuro
se termine el futuro miércoles claro en
los años hace casi 30 años hace casi 30
años
salió una película que fue catalogada
como la mejor película de ciencia
ficción del siglo 20 hablando de blade
runner cuando comienza dice los ángeles
noviembre
y estamos terminando noviembre de 2019
se termina el futuro pero bueno lo bueno
es que ya existe la película blade
runner 2049 claro que el 2009
yo no sé para el 2049 en qué estado se
encuentren seguros
42 años y tú paloma yo nada he pasado
una semana bastante interesante ha
habido muchos eventos aquí en canadá
esta semana hubo un evento de crisis
hablar un poco más adelante
sobre un poco la presencia canadiense en
el extranjero entonces estaba muy
envuelta en esto pensando repensar la
realidad
en la noticia y la noticia
a tiempo y bueno yo por mi parte vi algo
que me pareció muy curioso y que a lo
mejor ustedes vieron ya también en el
sitio de radio canadá se trata de esta
realidad virtual para reducir la
ansiedad si pierre nos pone el vídeo
vamos a ver la realidad virtual para
reducir la ansiedad en las vacas
así que me parece me pareció fantástico
esto es algo que este es una experiencia
que están haciendo en una finca lechera
en rusia así que decidieron ponerles
estos cascos virtuales a las vacas
porque al parecer les reduce la ansiedad
y al reducir la ansiedad la carne
no no estás son vacas lecheras
[Risas]
no porque me parecía me parecería pues
completamente increíble pues que para
los animales que van a ir al
[Música]
tranquilo
bueno es que también que de alguna
manera es igual de terrible que las
quieran poner tranquilidad antes de que
produzcan leche para que produzcan más
leche
no estamos aprovechando la gran pregunta
que me hago siempre que tomo un vaso de
leche que le pongo leche a mi café yo no
tomo leche café litros
un vasito de leche por aquí por allá y
bueno entonces si se toma leche pues
bien que sea de vaca relajada se ven con
esos tíos de turistas
dejando las vacas no tomamos las armas y
nos cambiaban a todos nos conviene
entonces pues eso era lo que eso fue lo
que a mí me pareció inédito y bien
anecdótico también y bueno ahora vamos a
regresar a nuestra invitada que ella es
el personaje central de esta reunión de
hoy más de lewis revelación radio canadá
2013-2014 si no se fue como como sucedió
eso sabes que yo misma no sé cómo
ocurrió eso y te voy a ser honesta
cuando yo supe esa noticia yo no sabía
el tamaño de la noticia o sea yo no
había comprendido hasta qué punto era
grande este pues esta nominación
justo cayó esta noticia en un momento en
el cual nosotros como productores
pequeños que somos nosotros somos un
equipo muy pequeñito estamos como casi a
punto de tirar la toalla si están muy
difíciles de llevar a cabo un proyecto
artístico hay mucho dinero que invertirá
hay mucho trabajo tiempo que invertir y
bueno estábamos así
y de repente nos hablas grande
finalmente la noticia de que man se les
dijo que una tortilla con queso
y al final pues bueno fue fue fue enorme
fue enorme al paso del año darnos cuenta
de y digo darme porque hicimos y así
comprendía
simón es mi marido y mi mujer en mi
agente claro que comprendía bien porque
él había también trabajado hace él es el
que me inscribió justamente a
la revelación y bueno después de eso yo
no sé exactamente cómo funciona todo el
sistema para después ser elegida como
tal artista revelación pero fue fue algo
enorme
yo tengo mucho mucho que agradecer a
radio canadá entonces yo creo que desde
ese entonces todo ese año en el que
recibimos promoción radio web televisión
eso eso cuesta una fortuna para un
artista como nosotros que no tenemos más
que lo que mi voz no yo tengo mi voz
para compartir bueno pues pues todo este
año hubo mucho crecimiento mucho como
muchas colaboraciones con otros artistas
la persona que estaba a cargo de
nosotros de la relación en mar y la
mujer muy gentil hizo proyectos ideas
muy interesantes de colaboraciones con
otras personas apariciones en escenarios
importantes muchas entrevistas y poco a
poquito aprendí a estar menos nerviosa a
decir abrir un poquito más para poder
conocer el terreno conocer terreno que
soy yo miraba que no sabían ni siquiera
que responder a las preguntas que me
hacían a hand yo sabía qué pasa tiempo
antes d
el pablo que es muy importante esta
nominación como revelación radio-canadá
porque representa digamos los artistas
de todo el canadá porque somos la radio
la televisión pública de todo el país
entonces se selecciona en todo el
territorio canadiense artistas de
diferentes estilos musicales géneros
musicales y si les da una visibilidad
muy grande durante ese año que son la
revelación pero la relación continúa me
imagino la relación continúa y claro que
pues la familia radio can nos nos ha
ayudado a lo largo de todos estos años
después de la revelación cada vez que
tenemos algún evento algo importante
hablamos a radio canadá y siempre hay
alguien siempre hay una apertura siempre
hay un apoyo casi tenemos tenemos un
vídeo de justamente eso
[Música]
y de la revelación y me gustaría que
nuestro amigo pierre no lo pusiera fue
justamente un vídeo que se hizo en
función de esta nominación que se te
hizo a ti
[Música]
los compositores e intérpretes de origen
méxico se estancó de swiss instalada en
la joven
la primera edición
me acompaña
están prendidos en este momento pues no
era justamente por esta nominación de
radio canadá como revelación como
revelación del 2013 y 2014 sí entiendo
bien tú habías llegado llega hasta acá
en el 2001 2009 2009 y 2009 porque eran
cuatro años más o menos de 43 años y
2009 y bueno ahorita va a hacer 10 años
de aquí
si vivimos de inviernos es rapidísimo
estoy como que en qué momento de acción
y en esos 10 años de vida artística
aquí en quebec sí entiendo bien ha sido
muy muy muy ocupados muy ocupados tan
ocupados que yo siento que
en todo el principio no tuve tiempo de
digerir tanto la lengua francófona como
mi llegada aquí
como quien como en quien me transformé
digamos que de repente ya estaba yo en
otro espacio ya estaba instalada y
estaba yo enraizadas transplantada y
todo muy rápido y hubo muchos regalos a
lo largo del camino no sin retos la
carrera artística es una es sinuosa es y
nuevos ahí es fantástica al mismo tiempo
que tiene estas dos contrastes y por eso
me gusta techo me gustan los retos y me
gusta me gusta vivir en este mundo
fantástico que porque creamos los
artistas
preguntarle por qué montreal porque en
contarles alguien eres alguien que
representa digamos muy bien la cultura
mexicana los sonidos mexicanos me parece
a mí es porque montreal del amor me
imagino
[Música]
hombre o mujer siempre hay una historia
de amor al cual pronto tal cual en
realidad yo que yo creo que desmontar
que no se inició a nosotros porque yo
encontré aunque de quad en méxico
estuvimos viajando en centroamérica y
trabajaba para el cirque du soleil en la
parte social del circo se llamaba
circuit del mundo
estuvimos viajando en diferentes lugares
y cuando nos pusimos el pie en la ciudad
de québec tuvimos la suerte que un amigo
nos dijo chicos hay una audición para
circo de soleil están buscando zanqueros
nosotros traemos los zancos en el coche
dijo un vayan ahorita porque llama a ver
si pues se abarataba tu nuevo mexicano
simón llamó véngase corriendo y llegamos
casi que tarde y los dos nos quedamos en
esta edición y a partir de ahí pues el
camino cambió completamente de yo yo
llegué aquí para quedarme un mes y al
final me quedé tres años porque después
pedimos la residencia y bueno lo demás
fue si se ve esa historia pero después
de estar en la ciudad de que venga un
tiempo
nos quedamos en montreal un ratito
estábamos cansados de tanto movimiento
la verdad y dijimos que en casa un
poquito de
y fue muy agradable y desde entonces
pues ya estamos acá que ya va a ser
desde el 2010 que nos quedamos aquí en
un trial aquí ya estamos llegando a los
10 y el francés
mi música y el francés bueno al
principio mi música de hecho en el
primer disco intenté a intentar
rápidamente y era ser francés porque me
fascinan las lenguas tengo que hay que
decir que los idiomas es algo que me que
me fascina y entonces ser en el disco
maíz puse un poema elegimos un poema que
musicalizamos bellísimo mujer
y justamente estaba escuchando hace
poquito tiempo esa canción
ok
pero este digo esa toma tiempo antes de
poder digerir en la musculatura sabes
como en el sonido vocal y claro que
siempre va a haber un acento civil
entonces bueno esa fue como un primer
intento en el disco número 2 no hubo
realmente este este acercamiento fue fue
un disco que surgió de una manera muy
espontánea y muy rápida y era un momento
en el que la revelación surgió entre
este premio de nominación así que nos
decidimos a lanzar el disco en ese
momento porque funcionaba ese era
perfecto timing para eso pero ahorita en
este disco en ese tercer disco
se dio natural que ya había canciones en
francés y de hecho tres piezas cuatro
sino 33 en francés pero no un 4
y estoy muy feliz porque tengo que ver
una parte de mí que sí se transformó a
se transmutó en el sentido de que ya
siento que el francés es parte del arte
en la lengua que aprendió la lengua
parte de uno puede hacer que yo estoy
atado a la silla con este alambre
soley del inah tú dices que hay tres
canciones en francés en solo cuatro
bases en francés pero el título está en
francés si originalmente no exactamente
soleil del inah el sol que nace de la
luna todos venimos de la madre y vamos
hacia la madre entonces es una evocación
en el título con respecto a esta visión
que tengo particularmente de
de la grandeza de esta energía femenina
y también es un título que evoca las dos
partes que por mucho tiempo me hicieron
sentir separada de mí misma es decir
esta parte luminosa esta parte dinámica
esta parte activa contra versus esta
otra parte melancólica problemática un
poco digamos oscura que es muy bonita
porque es la noche también pero que en
la cual a veces nos escondemos cosas es
a esta parte un poco delincuente la cual
yo había tenido mucho mucha dificultad
de aceptar de mí misma entonces al final
dije bueno este disco es finalmente la
decisión que tomó de unificar y de
aceptar la persona que soy con sus dos
unidades y sin miedo a mostrar esta
vulnerabilidad que todos tenemos al
final
y no sabes qué bien me siento desde esta
de esta decisión de unificar en un
trabajo artístico este camino de vida
este camino de trabajo interno un
trabajo personal y bueno tienen su
subtítulo que se llama aunque may efe
entre el mar y el fuego porque va a
haber un disco número 2 la ley del 11 y
su ley del 12 entonces o ley de lyon
aunque may efe que es esta parte y
luminosa y dinámica y soleil de un
eclipse que va a salir el siguiente año
todavía estamos trabajando
el lado más melodioso más introspectivo
más un poquito más esté más lunático
[Risas]
y mencionó que tiene clásicos de la
lengua francés de la lengua española
tiene la bohème que es una gran una gran
pieza también estas lágrimas negras y
quizás quizás quizás entonces bueno
grandes grandes títulos de las dos
lenguas
el comentario de rodríguez charlie dice
un saludo desde bogotá más tranquila
colombia nos alegramos martínez marvin
de estar mirando césar número uno de
blade runner al principio que abrir
gonzález nunca decía un saludo cordial y
un abrazote para mis buenos amigos de la
redacción en español de radicalmente
nacionales informó que ya tengo
instalada la aplicación de arce y por
cierto muy práctica
le digo a javier gonzález nunca hará que
le agradezco que si quiere hacer en todo
caso un vídeo diciendo que practica que
es gustavo lucas dice saludos desde la
ciudad de melo departamento desarrollar
con uruguay el presidente electo se
confirma a ser jueves la victoria del
candidato de colección multicolor louis
calle
javier gonzález no era los cordiales
para la invitada y además hay sana
mexicana
luís eduardo alfaro gómez saludos paloma
martínez desde aguascalientes y gustavo
lucas muy interesante felicito a la
invitada así que muchas más también a
los compatriotas hablábamos de los
clásicos ahorita que están acá en el
disco de mansell y me hace pensar
mansell una vez te escuché cantar un
clásico quebequense
invernal mucho nosotros no lo podemos lo
podemos representar me pareció
absolutamente fantástico que una
mexicana como tu cante esa canción
porque es muy quebequense y es como
bueno la gente cuando llegue el invierno
si desde esté viniendo detesta el frío
pero bueno hay una relación de amor y
odio creo con el invierno en ese país y
eso dio los primeros 10 minutos de la
primera nevada me gusta también pues uno
se va cansando mira me mata
40 centímetros a fines de abril y quiero
llamar al oficial
tengo una pregunta quizá indiscreta por
el mantel si quieres la responde y si no
pasamos a la próxima
bueno decías tienes 10 años
acá más o menos en quebec si tu nombre
artístico es mansell sí porque no sé
porque el hambre artístico es mi nombre
normal mi nombre de nacimiento es marcel
entonces por esa razón es más mi nombre
artístico orden decidí que mi nombre
artístico es el mismo nombre que por
toño
si acabamos de salir de todas las redes
sociales está por todos lados spotify
itunes en todas las plataformas
digitales por la gente que nos ve desde
desde otras partes les dije que es
bastante difícil conseguir el el cd
físico entonces siempre pregunta si se
puede conseguir la música por spotify si
yo soy mansell ruiz para que los que
estén con ganas de escuchar el producto
que lo recomendamos lo he escuchado un
par de veces aquí en radio canadá
en la típica que es una belleza así que
lo recomendamos y la pregunta la cia
porque en francés mademoiselle señorita
la gente a veces dice marcel exactamente
mansell entonces por eso me preguntaba
si era de [ __ ] ciudad tu nombre de pila
o si era un nombre de artistas aquí hay
una historia detrás de este nombre
bueno resulta que mi padre es los dos
mexicanos madre y padre este mi madre
está embarazada elisabeth mi padre se
fue de viaje a francia y bueno regreso
como todo mexicano con nuevas palabras
aprendidas en su boca como por ejemplo
toilette o forma de mums el como así no
entonces mi madre da nacimiento a
elisabeth y entonces cinco minutos
después trata
una niña sorpresa
sí señor
una gemela sorpresa entonces rápido
buscando nombres entre entre buscar
nombres y no mi padre bueno porque
habían pensado ponerme en maría josé
pero repitió tanto la palabra mouse el
dame a mansell cambiaré la curia mansell
sí como encontró muy cute decirme cómo
no llamarme de cariño mansell y al final
todos me decían 900 y juegos vamos a
ponerle mansell pero espera es como la
maldición porque nadie podría pronunciar
méxico nadie puede pronunciar mansell
todo dicen mansell morse él musel marcel
todo pero mantengo mansell ahí está esto
yo llego aquí y entonces digamos que la
maldición se persigue si es que se
continúa porque entonces ahora es cuál
es su nombre mansell no me puse la
versión 2 de la misma historia pero no
más que la maldición es una bendición
porque como cantante mansell en francés
bueno la gente se acuerda entonces pues
es un regalazo de verdad o sea gracias a
este nombre creo que hemos
a este camino
[Risas]
y bueno yo ya había comenzado su carrera
artística en méxico mansell me imagino
sí sí sí y cómo fue ese comienzo tú
tocas guitarra yo sé que te vimos en el
vídeo que toca la guitarra te acompaña
con la guitarra te iniciaste temprano en
la música muy temprano empecé a los 5
años a cantar en las iglesias
a los 10 años empecé a tocar la guitarra
mi papá me dio una guitarra bueno no me
la dio me la gané en una rifa gente que
dice que cree que todo pero bueno la
cuenta está negra está mi abuelita tenía
dos guitarras guardadas también en su
closet y yo las veía desde ahí y yo veía
la escuela había una rondalla entonces
yo me inscribí a la rondalla mi abuelita
me prestó su guitarra y después yo le
había echado el ojo a la guitarra a mi
padre y entonces yo ya había aprendido
una cancioncilla por ahí y le dije a mi
papá oye si aprende una canción me das
tu guitarra y pues no me quedé yo mismo
bueno la siguiente ocasión que viene a
verlo porque no vivíamos con el padre le
digo oye qué crees ya me aprendí la
canción que como que no le habías dicho
que si yo me aprendía finalmente me
aprendí la canción y como tú me habías
dicho que me ibas a dar tu guitarra
entonces te vine a cantar las canciones
de todas maneras ya me tendría que
mandar a hacer otra súper bello bien
preciosa me encantaba todavía la tengo
por ahí en casa mi madre sí que toca la
guitarra se dan un palo no fue eso sería
se llama paloma tú le pusiste balón así
se llama paloma porque ella y yo volamos
juntas en el escenario y es la paloma de
la paz entonces yo mi guitarra está
hecha para hacer la paz para generar la
paz así que por eso y cuando descubriste
esa voz porque tú tienes una voz muy
especial y maravillosa entonces bueno la
guitarra fue como el inicio de algo de
algo así pero digamos cuando te dijiste
a ti misma puedo hacer camino con mi voz
y con mi guitarra sabes que nunca lo
pensé
no es que se hizo solo no simplemente
empecé a cantar y nunca paré cuando toco
el momento de elegir carrera pues era
evidente que era usted así me urgía a
salir
la preparatoria para irme a la escuela
de música hay gente que estaba perdiendo
el tiempo así que llegué a la escuela de
música es como llegué a casa ok me
olvido de las materias que no me
distraen y al final pues hice largo
camino en la escuela de ópera en la
escuela de jazz con maestros privados y
sobre todo en el escenario
de tuve oportunidad de encontrar grandes
maestros también entonces creo que he
tenido mucha suerte
me siento muy privilegiada de todos los
encuentros con todos los coaches y
maestros y cuando vas a méxico qué tal
la respuesta a tu música lo que
presentas a lo que les propones fíjate
que el público mexicano es el
maravilloso y ven talento y buen ritmo y
enseguida funciona y bueno además el
público mexicano es muy muy caluroso muy
efusivo muy fans sabes el que la cultura
del ser fan
es como vivir o si es así porque aquí
hay fans personas que se quedan muy
tranquilos respetuosos del mar se creo
que en montreal es uno de los destinos
favoritos de las start the hollywood
porque nadie le dice nada por ahí una
self y un autógrafo de vez en cuando
pero pueden comer tranquilos pueden
pasar tranquilos nadie les molesta como
que estamos nosotros conocemos si nos
podemos con la gente no nos molestamos y
una vez bien robert de niro a robert de
niro en un restaurante aquí en montreal
y la gente lo respetaba tanto nadie se
acercaba porque no me molestan y no era
un restaurante lujoso bang bang están
justamente me imagino que cuando eres
muy conocido en algún lugar pues te vas
a lugares más exclusivos donde hay menor
gente así pero este restaurante del que
les hablo es un restaurante muy normal
no de precio normal y estaba ahí con sus
hijos y son virus
[Risas]
y miran y hacen el gesto pero uno
reconoce dos se sienten halagados pero
no es la molestia de un mundo corriendo
eso pasa en méxico si puedes llegar a
ser y sobre todo que bueno a mí me gusta
mucho ser excéntrica en el escenario en
la vida normal soy más más normal
es común para mí el escenario es es un
santuario y en ese santuario me encanta
jugar y me encantan los colores las
plumas los maquillajes las fantasías
entonces claro que pues la cultura que
de cúa en esa área es muy fuerte pues
cuando yo vengo a méxico y que ya traigo
incluido todo mi aprendizaje me van gas
que adquiría aquí pues digamos que ya se
ve algo como más más grande más más pues
el excentricismo siempre es como llama
mucho más atractivo entonces eso pasa
que yo llego allá con pues con mis ropas
coloridas cientos la gente es como guay
y de repente a ser yo digo yo creo que
tengo que estar más discreta por la
calle
[Música]
y nos dice gracias paloma martínez voy a
comprar sucede y javier gonzález nunca
de todos los escucha mientes queremos
que los invitados del programa se
sientan en confianza así que por eso el
mandan saludos y los apoyan desde
nuestras transmisiones en las redes
sociales vamos a regresar con bam cel
por el momento leo la aplicación ya
vimos que está dando resultados
javier la recomienda me encantó la
palabra que usó un segundo segundo que
la encuentro deja es muy práctica me
encantó así que vamos a ver la wta la
practicidad de nuestra aplicación
ustedes pueden ir a las dos tiendas más
importantes esto es apple store y google
play para bajar la aplicación en español
les recomendamos en español aunque
ustedes ven en la pantalla están las
cinco lenguas de radio canal
internacional si ustedes la bajan en
español tienen acceso también a las
noticia
más importantes en francés y en inglés
así que las lenguas oficiales de canadá
ustedes van a ese lugar tipean radio
canadá internacional o rs y español y
ahí aparece nuestra aplicación la bajan
y tienen una navegación mucho más fácil
mucho más dinámica así que les aconsejo
como hizo javier hace un rato bajar la
aplicación y probar bueno ahora javier
tiene que grabar un pequeño vídeo diga
quién es la medicación es ahí yo los
invito a que se haga
la aplicación es buena
mansell va a asegurar voy a bajar a
bajar ahora también sucedió que yo soy
yo soy adicta acá recibe nada me encanta
radio canadá hay ciertos programas que
sigo me encanta mi pasión así aprendo a
hablar en francés y ahí sigo escuchando
en español
seguramente ya todo el mundo lo sabe yo
soy de barranquilla colombia o en serio
un pueblo alegre con viandero y bueno
eso es porque les quiero mostrar un
vídeo que nos envió un oyente que es un
viejo oyente de radio canal
internacional y al mismo tiempo es un
viejo amigo mío de infancia entonces se
llama william enrique señor ariza él
hizo un pequeño vídeo que nos que nos
mandó sobre la navidad de ella la
navidad pero hay que decir que la fiesta
en barranquilla son los carnavales de
barranquilla que duran cuatro días
cuatro meses este año oficialmente es
del 22 de al 25 de febrero del martes 22
y digo del sábado 22 al martes 25 de
febrero
pero ya desde ya estamos apenas a
finales de noviembre y como nos va a
mostrar este vídeo ya está bien
debe estar sudando papá noel
digo palanquilla para calorcito que hace
es una pasada
una muestra de lo que va a ser el
carnaval de barranquilla esa canción es
un clásico del carnaval y de las
navidades también se llama las cuatro
fiestas aunque las cuatro fiestas que es
de un gran compositor
de la cuota llama al golfo
[Música]
en navidad negra
colombiana canción afro colombiana digo
nada más ahora que hablas el carnaval
digo bueno es que yo me inspiré mos en
navidad negra ahora lo vamos a escuchar
nunca hagas amenazas a las dos mesas
bueno el tiempo se nos va como agua
entre los dedos muy rápidamente para
poder regresar con mansell después vamos
a ver los temas que resaltamos esta
semana leonora german está ausente pero
ella por su lado nos invita a escuchar
una entrevista con john kirk profesor de
estudios latinoamericanos en la
universidad dalhousie en halifax nueva
escocia y se para quien la política
exterior canadiense va a la deriva en
latinoamérica el plano no salió
paloma tú vas a a ese es el reportaje de
leonora sobre la política exterior
canadiense es una entrevista con el
profesor ron kirk y si yo voy along a la
misma vía pero no solamente en américa
latina sino más bien a nivel de el mundo
entero hubo una cumbre en ottawa esta
semana el 27 y el 28 de noviembre hasta
ayer entonces que trató justamente de
hacerse esta gran pregunta es ahora de
repente
a la política exterior de canadá
entonces en la cumbre se llama cumbre
sobre el liderazgo canadiense en el
mundo y en el evento hubo representantes
de la diplomacia canadiense académicos
políticos hubo gente de las
organizaciones de desarrollo
internacional que son canadienses
entonces es muy interesante leer qué es
lo que a las conclusiones a las que
llegar el recinto sea recuérdense de eso
y tú leonardo nos dices que un ex
campeón de afirma que la inteligencia
artificial es invencible
lo explico es un juego es un juego que
tiene en realidad como lo describen como
el santo grial de la computación porque
tiene tantas variables tantas
posibilidades es un juego ustedes lo han
visto en realidad es el juego que uno
tiene piezas blancas y negras y si uno
encierra una pieza da vuelta a la del
medio a su color y así el otro tiene que
ir a la bueno en realidad es el santo
grial de la cuestión de la acción de la
inteligencia artificial sobre todo
porque la cantidad de posibilidades de
movimientos son increíbles y este hombre
que vivía de eso hace 30 años que es
campeón de go y que hace ese juego por
parte es milenario en corea es un juego
realmente el par coreano el coreano es
robo de ano y este buen hombre
hace dos años atrás en el 2016 perdió un
partido con al fango que es un
desarrollo que fue comprado por google
que desarrolla justamente inteligencia
artificial y
hicieron una serie de cinco partidos en
el ganó una y después dijo que había
ganado esa porque google se había
equivocado una partecita del algoritmo
no porque lo voy a tener la capacidad de
hacerlo y ahora salió alfa ago 20
y es aprende sola de ella misma y dale
ganó a la que le ganó al coreano al
coreano dijo esto es invencible ahí
vamos eso lo que tienen la mala
costumbre que tienen esas máquinas que
aprenden solas
bueno yo por mi parte les quiero lo
quiero invitar a que lean un artículo
sobre la gordo fobia que fue algo que me
llamó mucho la atención en francés le
dicen la groso fobia y
entonces estuve tratando de rastrear qué
era esto de la groso fobia y encontré me
fui a la aldea diccionario de la real
academia española de la lengua no existe
gordo fobia en fin finalmente toda esa
información está ahí en ese en ese
artículo y pues es un fenómeno todo esto
porque hay una mujer que tiene un sitio
abre un sitio internet de gross o fobia
punto con punto sea punto sea y quiere
que se introduzca en el artículo 10 de
la carta de derechos y libertades de
quebec la discriminación hacia las
personas con sobrepeso entonces pues lo
pueden leer en nuestro sitio internet
antes de que se me olvide en los
controles técnicos allá del otro lado de
la ventana
benoit durán leo cullen
el infaltable pierde
irremplazable piel que cariñosamente le
decimos también lo útil
y regresado con nuestra invitada mansa
ya nos quedan pocos minutos pero bueno
que es verdaderamente un gran placer
tenerte aquí con nosotros en lo
inmediato cuál es la cuáles son los
proyectos los proyectos bueno es lo que
terminamos ahorita que se lanzó el
lanzamiento del 22 de noviembre lanzamos
un espectáculo que viene acompañando el
proyecto soleil del wing porque sólo del
1 nada más es un disco pero es un
espectáculo un espectáculo sobre todo de
música pero que contiene danza y
contiene circo es la primera vez que
como yo les decía quería yo unificar mis
dos partes que estaban una para allá y
una para acá
gracias a este proyecto finalmente mi
carrera decir que era en mi carrera de
músico entonces finalmente viene el día
para generar este nuevo proyecto que
bueno esperamos ahora que después de que
el lanzamiento se ocurrió en el cuadro
de mundial montreal este show que es muy
muy popular
esperamos ahorita tejer una nueva gira
para 2020 y bueno hay como muchas cosas
que están perfilando en el calendario
que están todavía en standby pero pues
ahorita nos vamos a descansar un poquito
exactamente norte nos vamos en un
clavado en enero-febrero a justamente
haga continuar en el trabajo pero pasan
ganas porque está la nieve cita y así
y bueno tenemos todavía tiempo de sobra
tenemos 73 minutos todavía una eternidad
una eternidad y que luego se lo vamos a
dedicar a mansell
no puede dijo que es más él
nosotros somos latinos
[Música]
toda una cosa y mansell entonces esta
gira de la que estabas mencionaste es
ahorita
va a ser internacional les digo en otras
palabras los que nos están allá escucha
viendo del otro lado tendrán la
oportunidad de verte en algún momento
allá por sus lares pues esperemos que sí
ahorita pues no estoy trabajando esté
colaborando en méxico con una persona
que me está haciendo es mi personaje sus
personas en méxico contacto de contacto
en méxico con la cual estamos
desarrollando mercado allá y bueno
probablemente que vamos a tejer algo por
allá en méxico estamos planeando un
proyecto que es esto había un proyecto
piloto una sorpresa en la cual no puedo
hablar mucho pero es probable que varias
personas que nos siguen por acá
probablemente que nos las vamos a llevar
por ahí
para que hablemos más en profundidad de
este proyecto y que quizás si quieren se
vienen con nosotros ellos sí y bueno eso
es entonces ahorita lo que lo que resta
es bueno ese es el inicio de algo porque
bueno de miel de cactus que fue la
última gira pues sí sí ya este duro que
al menos cuatro años y medio bastante
largo normalmente un disco tiene tres
años de vida y bueno este duro se alargó
y ahora bueno pues gracias a aquí eso
ley de luna que va a tener pues los dos
discos yo creo que vamos a yo porque
bueno los próximos al menos cuatro o
cinco años este vamos a estar sorteando
en las playas del caribe y avisando
cuando hablamos de gira internacional
mansell si se contempla ahí suramérica o
no tenemos muchas ganas hay contactos
que se están desarrollando probablemente
en tu país colombianito en méxico y
bueno pues entrada creo que tenemos que
volver a hacer nuestro resto nuestra red
aquí en quebec y bueno vamos a relanzar
nuestros contactos latinos para ver si
ahora sí en esta ocasión nos vamos más
para abajo más para el centro y para el
sur él se le para la europa también muy
bien eso ahora sí se nos acabó el tiempo
muchísimas gracias mansell muy amable de
haber aceptado la invitación aquí en el
estudio para martínez leonardo gimeno y
mi persona les agradecemos a ustedes
allá del otro lado por su alta fidelidad
así que les deseo un feliz fin de semana
adiós ya está
[Música]
ah